what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here
with her that's right it's friday and
we're here
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products they allow you to buy and
sell crypto on a crypto exchange they
allow you to deposit crypto and take out
a new style alone and get your crypto
collateral
or three my favorite product her
favorite product everyone's favorite
product
i'm an investor i sit on the board but
we use the interest bearing account go
get an interest bearing account
you can earn up 8.6 epy in that account
all you do is you deposit money money
money money
and they turn it into a stable coin or
you can deposit crypto
like bitcoin and earn up to eight point
six percent apy
in the interest pairing account block
five dot com slash pomp
go do it block five dot com slash pomp
bang bang get money get paid what's up
hey by the way i hear that all of you
are very worried about my energy levels
don't worry i got that friday energy
today yeah yesterday he hadn't had us
coffee yet
no i didn't have my coffee but today
he's still sticking the straws in there
yeah we don't even need to get into the
conversation about the
starbucks straws give us the straws
nobody wants to drink out of a sippy cup
like you're three years old
just put the straws in there let's go
get special straws if you're worried
about the environment or do whatever you
got to do
with this whole like drink it like
you're a sippy cup and then it spills
everywhere it's
nonsense today it is nonsense today he
got mad at the
lady at starbucks well no we left
starbucks
and he said oh that was just foolish
yeah
i said can you put milk in my coffee and
the woman literally handed me the coffee
and then she handed me a paper cup with
milk
i came here to starbucks i paid your
over your overpriced coffee
and now you give me like a make your own
milk in your coffee so i had to go
outside pour some out
i was like what am i doing a science
experiment on the sidewalk
fools all right let's go
okay that was foolish the u.s has a debt
hangover
okay so basically the u.s federal budget
is on an
unsustainable path and it has been for
some time says
jerome powell federal reserve chairman
this is not the time to give priority to
those concerns what
uh foolish foolish when the country
eventually pulls out of its current
health and economic crises
americans will be left with a debt
hangover on thursday the congressional
budget office
estimated for fiscal year 2020 which
ended september 30th
the us deficit hit 3.13 trillion or
15.2 percent of gdp thanks to the chasm
between what the country
spent 6.55 trillion and what it took
took in 3.42 trillion for the year that
means that
the debt is now projected to be larger
than the u.s
economy 51
of the 52 countries that have ever hit
130 percent debt to gdp ratio
have defaulted what does it mean to
default
did the aliens come and like make you
pay take your stuff
the important part here is a three
trillion dollar deficit
in one fiscal year
are these people nuts i feel like i'm in
trouble
i'm not even part of the deficit what
are they doing three trillion dollars
that's more than 10
of the total national debt it ain't
an income problem they keep taking more
and more national
or a federal income off taxes
every year the federal taxes for
federal income tax is higher and higher
every year the last six fiscal years
it isn't a problem of taking money in
it's a spending problem this is insane
but here's a fun fact
the debt hasn't been this high since
1946 when the federal debt was 106.1
percent
of gdp
remember they may they may approve
another two trillion dollar stimulus
package
tell them about your kidney oh
i saw on twitter somebody said that
somebody in the trump administration i
think it was a joke but i wasn't sure
so i just ran with it but somebody said
that they're looking at a bigger
spending bill
maybe it'll be 10 trillion dollars and i
said if they approve a 10 trillion
dollar bill i'm selling one of my
kidneys and i'm buying more bitcoin
that would be insane but another two
trillion dollars is likely and if that
happens
that would put us in uh it's technically
gonna be outside the fiscal year
but if it wasn't that would put us at a
five trillion dollar deficit
in one year hmm
this this is lit we're at the point now
where this is just insanity but go ahead
central banks are weighing their own
digital currencies
and they're saying so the bank
for international settlements and
several central banks published a report
laying out some key requirements for
central bank
digital currencies or cbdc's
they recommended that cbdc's
complement but not replace cash
and other forms of legal tender and that
they don't harm
monetary and financial stability at this
point can we even harm it more
what do you think bitcoin puts central
banks in the innovator's dilemma
oh you wrote about that today yeah i
mean that's all it is
central banks they can't disrupt
themselves they're
too locked into the current model
writing's on the wall technology's going
to disrupt them
so they're just going to create i'm 32
i probably got 60 years
left i don't know yeah that's probably
about right
by the time that i died probably about
85
90 year old is the uh is life expectancy
we're at like 77 78 years old right now
so let's say i lived in 90 i got 60
years left in my
in my lifetime we will see central banks
disrupted
it'll happen in the next six decades and
it probably will happen much faster than
that probably happened in the next
i if i had to guess my guess is that
this is a
10 to 15 year exercise
of complete disruption of the central
bank system as we know it today
we'll see put it on the record but
what's today's date
friday october 9th 2020
10 to 15 years we'll see
next the covet 19
crisis and an ongoing nationwide
shortage of qualified
teachers have created a perfect storm in
the education system
that may only worsen in months to come
basically educators are being forced to
make tough decisions about their own
health and safety and that of family
members
data from the american federation of
teachers which is the national labor
union shows that one in three teachers
say the pandemic has made them more
likely
to retire earlier than planned
particularly among those over age 50 and
more than 20 years of tenure the
american enterprise institute projected
that more than 18 percent of all public
and private school teachers
are in the 65 and older age group
that's most vulnerable to the virus but
the point is that the education system
is a mess right now
virtual learning home learning all sorts
of learning
distance learning and now teachers are
leaving
and now it's just going to be a complete
mess
just saying well we know that the
education system needs a complete
overhaul
the united states is one of the worst at
educating
uh at the education system when you
measure it up against other things
so yeah rather than look at this all as
a challenge look at it as an opportunity
how do we disrupt the whole thing
how do we yeah how do we bring in better
teachers how do we make the environment
safe and better the way you bring in
better teachers you pay them
right to be the best yeah we should pay
teachers
teachers should be looked at in my
opinion
as the most worthy occupation i agree
but also the teachers shouldn't be in a
classroom
just put them on youtube i think some of
them are on youtube already but they're
not getting paid
oh they're getting paid if they're on
youtube trust me i don't know that's why
they're on youtube because they're
making money
i don't that's what happens speaking of
rich
the 50 richest americans now hold almost
as much wealth as half of the us
as kova transforms the economy in ways
that have disproportionately awarded a
small class of billionaires
new data from the u.s federal reserve
said that
okay hold on so while the top one
percent of americans have a combined net
worth of 34.2 trillion
the poorest 50 about 165 million people
hold just 2.08 trillion or 1.9 percent
of all household wealth
wow isn't this your rich get richer
forget poorer theory
the federal reserve pretending like
coronavirus did this is
absurd
the federal reserve did this literally
the fed
made billionaires worth this much money
well and also the stock market keeps
going up but it's not like the bottom
fifty percent are benefiting
benefiting from it of course but the
stock market's going up because the
fed's pumping asset prices
so literally the federal reserve is
making these 50 people richer than
everybody else and they're publishing
reports like oh this is a problem
they don't think it's a problem it is a
part of the system the system is working
how it's designed
this is not a bug this is exactly how
the system's designed
those who hold assets get rich those who
don't get poor and
if you want to have the system work for
you get out of cash
this is interesting it says that the
millennial generation
controls just 4.6 percent of u.s wealth
even though they are the largest in the
workforce with 72 million members
that's interesting that'll change you
think well yeah as people die
the wealth transfer there's trillions of
dollars that's going to transfer hands
from
everyone's parents to the kids like that
i mean that's always happened right
look again i've said this way too many
times if you're watching this for the
first time go watch old videos
the federal reserve has created this
inequality and based on their
constant need to intervene in markets
they're going to continue to make it
worse i've been saying since march
the federal reserve is going to pump
asset prices and make the rich richer in
the poor poor and now everyone's yelling
and screaming about no this has always
been happening but don't you think that
kobet kind of
pointed it out like made it off no if
the fed
didn't step in and do this in terms of
print all this money everyone would have
gotten poorer together
the rich would have lost money and the
poor would have lost money as well it's
going like this
exactly because what they did is they
stepped in and they decided
they had an option you can choose to
save one of the two groups
and they saved the rich people they
didn't they didn't do they
is anybody still enjoying those twelve
hundred dollars from march
no but the rich people the socialists on
wall street
got their assets pumped and they all got
rich can i ask what the other option
would have been
to if they had decided to save the
bottom 50
what they should have done is done
nothing that's what they should have
done
and they should have said hey this is
going to be painful as hell
for everybody but we got to all get
through this together that's what they
should have done
but they didn't do that they decided to
intervene and if they wanted to save the
bottom 50
what they should have done is they
should have printed the money and handed
it right to the people
but instead what they did is they bailed
out the airlines think about this these
idiots run in the airlines idiots these
people are so stupid are they foolish
they're they're so beyond foolish the
worst insult you could say to a
grown-ass man is to call them silly and
these people are
silly that's what these people are you
know why they're silly because they took
their cash
they did stockpile they did stock
buybacks
they paid themselves all these bonuses
and then when the rainy day came and
they didn't do the work it was necessary
to make sure that they could survive the
rainy day they ran to the government and
got a bailout
they used taxpayer money for a bailout
for the airlines
and now they're back asking for more we
just gave them a bailout
how about you bail out the people you
want to bail somebody out go bail out
the people
go help the people who are getting not
rich right now because the airlines
they're doing just fine
it's crazy and then we got reports
coming up the rich are getting richer
and everyone yells and screams at the
rich people
jeff bezos did nothing jeff bezos
literally he's been selling stocking
getting richer
he took a third of his wealth and he
gave it to his ex-wife and he's still
the richest man in the world
so how is it that the guy who gave away
a third of his wealth to his ex-wife
literally and so much money no no it's
because the asset prices have
exploded so he's just getting richer and
richer and richer but it's not like jeff
bezos is sitting there saying like
basically what investment should i make
today amazon between two months ago and
today
even if it didn't add any new value its
stock price would have continued to go
up
is what you're saying of course well
over the last six months the last six
months right
all right i'm i'm good now i'm good
that's that friday energy can you exhale
no everybody was saying i had low energy
now you got that friday energy yes i
know i'm deaf
um dollar general the retail powerhouse
known for its
rock bottom prices is opening a new
store
aimed at a higher-end suburban shopper
you see how i did that he was on his
phone because i'm looking at something
okay
the company is launching its first two
top shelf stores in nashville in the
coming weeks
and plans to open another 30 by the end
of next year what is a pop shelf store
it's a little bit higher end than your
regular dollar general
why is it called pop shelf unclean is
that the name of the store yes
um but it's interesting now in a time
where so many stores brick and mortar
are
closing that dollar general seems to be
doing so well that they're
opening stores well dollar general laid
the groundwork for this
year like three or four years ago when
they started to go into bedroom
communities that walmart wasn't in
and they basically picked okay if we go
to places that are just big enough
to have actual commerce but they're too
small for a walmart
that's going to be our like our sweet
spot so
like in roanoke rapids north carolina
there's a walmart
but in littleton north carolina there's
not a walmart there's a dollar general
and they you
and the people in that community use the
dollar general the same way that you
would use a walmart
and so dollar general systematically
went across the country doing this
and so what ends up happening is i think
during
a profile on their leadership and i feel
like they're pretty smart
like they've done an interesting yeah
we'll see if pop shelf pop shelf is
targeting women
in suburban areas that earn between 50
000 and 125
000 a year all right moving on
waymo
so waymo finally launches an actual
public
driverless taxi service
fully driverless technology is real and
now you can try it in the phoenix area
is there nobody sitting in the i do not
believe driver's seat
what yep no wait this is
so in 2018 waymo every vehicle had a
safety driver and the service was only
open to a small group of people but
today
waymo finally seems to be launching the
taxi service they promised two years ago
one that's fully driverless and open to
the public
the service will initially operate in a
50 square mile area in the phoenix
suburbs of chandler
tempe tim and mesa i don't know
yeah for real for real there's no people
in there no
there is no there's not eliminating the
safety driver is an important step
these weibo staffers never steer the
vehicles directly but they do have high
level
oh so i think what ends up happening is
they have remote drivers remote
overseers
whatever that means uh you ain't gonna
catch me in one of these
nope you don't want to be on the camera
i don't care about any camera i'm not
the guinea pig
you're not putting me in the car but
remember in vegas we wanted to try one
with a human driver there in case
something goes wrong
you guys go try it out let me know how
it goes cool
all right ready for my joke this better
be a friday energy joke
son do you know why the pictures
wait okay why don't you go back to the
monday energy
why do you know why the picture was sent
to jail
no because it got framed
i knew that was a false but it's funny
it is funny all right guys that's it
i hope you guys appreciate the friday
energy
so you know what that was bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends